the eight long pointed lengths of a
massive spider fangs dripping with
Deadly Venoms skitter across the ground
it is one of the apex predators here
until it's crushed by the scaly foot of
scp-682 the back room's newest angriest
resident when we last left our least
favorite anomalous reptile
scp-682 was eight levels deep into the
terrifying extra-dimensional Labyrinth
known as the back rooms with scp-343
knows how many levels left to Traverse
the hard to destroy reptile was
beginning to feel a bubbling sense of
contempt for everything in this
god-forsaken reality that is to say
scp-682 felt this way it usually felt
but for once there was no feeble
Foundation Personnel to unleash its rage
on and while its long absence back in
the world outside of the back rooms has
been seen as a stressful inconvenience
for most of the foundation the fact that
the ketter class creature had done no
further harm since it evaded containment
had led many researchers to believe that
however unlikely it was
scp-682 no longer existed it's out of
our hair said one Dr Wazowski though the
foundation would continue to launch
Around the Clock reconnaissance missions
the world over the mobile task force
that seemingly did the deed of
destroying the hard to destroy reptile
was currently being treated to a company
pizza party paid for by the foundation's
Saria lizard ate your loved one fund
which received a small donation from the
o5 council every time that scp-682
breached containment but there was no
chance of relief for scp-682 itself as
wandering through the back rooms without
a map or strong sense of purpose was
certainly no pizza party level 8 the
level that scp-682 currently found
itself on was a Cave System crawling
with all manner of hostile entities well
hostile for a weak and pathetic human
beings at least to say the same was true
for scp-682 would be a gross Distortion
of the definition of the word hostile
especially because scp-682 had faced
many of these miserable monstrosities
before on the previous levels the clumps
hounds death rats and smilers were back
in droves and these now all two familiar
entities seemingly couldn't help
themselves from aggressively pouncing on
scp-682 the second that the reptile
entered their line of sight not that
getting the drop on the anomaly would
buy them any advantage as scp-682
effortlessly bodied them one after
another playing the hits already back
rooms
scp-682 thought to itself at least give
me something new to chew on through the
jumbo of stalactites and stalagmites
scp-682 could see a child faceling
standing on the other side of an unusual
pit of tar the last time that scp-682
encountered a few of these unfittingly
named faceless little girls during its
time on level 2 it had ignored the
entities out of a sense that there would
be more interesting monster to destroy
going forward
scp-682 now realized almost shamefully
that it had largely been proven wrong
perhaps the child facelings were in fact
more than meets the eye or knew
something that the other entities didn't
regardless there were never enough
pathetic cretans in the back rooms for
scp-682 to vent its nine Limitless
frustration on the small faceling would
simply be the next to bite the dust or
so
scp-682 thought as the hard to destroy
reptile charge towards the entity its
cause touched down on the puddle of tar
and almost immediately a countless
number of human hands emerge from the
liquid beneath and pulled 682 under the
anomaly was able to easily adapt the
level of strength necessary to escape
from the grasp of the tar pit entities
and resurface when it emerged however
the child face thing was nowhere to be
found
scp-682 had given the creepy little
Menace some credit as it was apparently
smarter than the other entity disease
which had crossed the lizard's path
scp-682 put its much distance between
itself and that an annoying tar pit as
it could and it was vigilant for any
other similar hazards not especially
amused by the concept of being swallowed
up again
scp-682 adapted a pair of large draconic
Wings which it used to carry itself
Aloft through the caves of level 8. from
above the anomaly could see a number of
foot long centipede-like entities as
well as entities that resembled eyeless
chickens and for once neither of these
horrendous mistakes of creation seemed
interested in assaulting
scp-682 it was surprising but scp-682
actually felt a little bit relieved not
because it felt remotely threatened by
anything that crawled trotted or slung
through the back rooms but because it
didn't have to waste any of its valuable
time putting down another weakling that
should know better this relief was
short-lived as all of a sudden a large
shape dropped down on scp-682 from the
ceiling this monstrous human humanoid
boasted four powerful Limbs and was
currently using all of them in an
attempt to Pummel scp-682 back down to
the ground 682 could see several similar
entities emerging from nearby Cavern
walls having apparently Blended in
through color changing camouflage and
lying completely still and wait for prey
or in the case of scp-682 the anomalous
lizard that would prey on them these
entities are called camo crawlers by the
major Explorer group and because they
have the same level of intelligence as
regular humans and cooperate to hunt in
packs they are regarded as one of the
most difficult entities to deal with not
for scp-682 of course and the hateful
bees could not be more disappointed in
this latest ill-conceived Ambush
scp-682 came to a landing on part of the
cavern floor which was decidedly not
covered with tar and allowed its wings
to retract back to its body without a
moment to spare it quickly made short
work of the cam crawlers a lot of them
may have been as smart as humans but
scp-682 had killed a lot of humans in
its time and an extra pair of arms
wasn't exactly a game changer now
surrounded by a record number of expired
back rooms entities
scp-682 realized it was growing sick of
level 8. it seemed that there was no
winning with this place as the levels
that scp-682 had visited previously
either contain hordes of worthless
Expendable fodder like this one or were
so empty that the SCP would find itself
longing for any kind of interaction it
was time to search for an exit to this
level with the hope that the next
inconceivably vast Maze of nothingness
had a more refreshing flavor to it
knowing the back rooms the exit to level
8 would probably come in the form of an
off-color portion of the cave wall or
some glitched geometry straight out of
those video games that younger humans
seem to love to play fortunately
scp-682 didn't have to think too hard
about how to progress to the next level
as after wandering around for long
enough it merely fell straight through a
random section of the floor Into
Darkness seconds later
scp-682 appeared in the Lamppost lit
streets of level 9 also known as the
infinite suburb it looked close to
midnight and much like in Michael
Jackson's hit song Thriller evil things
were no doubt lurking in the dark but
none more evil than the hard to destroy
reptile itself if level 9 was anything
like the suburbs that scp-682 remembered
from its native reality this place
should be filled with humans packed
together like sardines in a can and
while the lucky Foundation mobile task
force that was present at the site
scp-682 had no clipped into the back
room's act were likely enjoying some
sardine pizza for a job well done
scp-682 was fixing to make the next
humans it encountered into its own kind
of unconventional topping for a feast it
was feeling oddly rejuvenated did and
almost happy again but what it didn't
know was that the darkness of level 9
had the same anomalous or I suppose
vaguely Supernatural properties of level
six and as the research suggests many
kinds of emotional inversion fields that
unnerve and disturb ordinary humans make
scp-682 feel the opposite way it was
strange but somehow scp-682 felt almost
like it belonged here in Suburbia just a
little old me in a big big world
scp-682 moves to itself before trotting
down the pavement through the
neighborhood its mouth was starting to
water as it carefully deliberated over
which of these sleepy community homes it
would enter first the idea that behind
every door there were unsuspecting
humans fresh for the slaughter made this
place seem like a paradise for the
reptile this rare good mood even
remained as a new group of quote-unquote
hostile entities made their way down the
street towards SCP 682 alright then
let's meet the welcoming committee these
entities were known as the neighborhood
watch and the most relatively
interesting thing about their appearance
was that their Anatomy seemed to be
centered around singularly massive
eyeballs without hesitation one of these
cyclopean entities a floating eyeball
known as Watcher fired a piercing ray of
light at scp-682 which instantly
disintegrated portions of the reptile's
body on contact unlike the corrosive
acid used by the death moss and the oh
bursters from Level 5 God the damage
inflicted on scp-682 was at the atomic
level what this effectively meant is
that the Regeneration time to recover
from these injuries was going to be
slightly longer than usual the other
advantage that the Watchers had was
strength in numbers as it were three of
them as well as a pair of Striders
ambulatory eyeballs on eight foot legs
which brought up the rear of the
neighborhood watch two can play at that
game said scp-682 it instantly copied
the Watcher's disintegration Rays firing
a pair of atomic lasers from both eyes
that would make a superhuman blush these
lasers of heat and light hit their marks
with perfect accuracy and dismantled
particles of the entire approaching
neighborhood watch as per usual the back
rooms then proceeded to roll out the
usual clown car of Stooges
scp-682 could see death moths a couple
skin Stealers and some particularly
wretched wretches hiding amongst the
suburban homes the reptile made a sport
of using its newly adapted laser vision
to pick them off one by one zap I see
you zap before long there were no more
backrooms entities in sight and scp-682
decided that it was time to break into
one of the homes on the street and go to
town or technically go to Suburbia honey
I'm home
scp-682 thought to itself as it smashed
through the front door or of one of the
buildings inside was no trace of
habitation no food no photographs and
absolutely no humans oh well thought 682
still mellowed out from the effects of
the darkness there's always next door it
exited through the hole in the wallet
made and Strode across the lawn to the
next Little House on the Square knock
knock
scp-682 burst in once more and found
this house to be much the same state as
the last undaunted and feeling
persistent
scp-682 made its way down the street
like a terrifying door-to-door salesman
bursting through the front door of every
house in its path telegram special
delivery I'm here to talk to you about
your car's Insurance there was nothing
no humans anywhere level 9 seemed to be
one big empty Ghost Town
scp-682 started to consider the
implications of the number of entities
it had encountered earlier while they
were little more than distraction for
682 the chances were very slim that any
humans that had made it this far could
have survived such a plethora of Dime
Store goofballs
scp-682 let out an uncharacteristically
wistful sigh the backgrounds have me all
messed up I can't believe I'm actually
missing those disgusting humans I've
grown accustomed to their faces
scp-682 reflected on this for a moment
and then had another realization no this
is perfect I'm free I may never see
these worthless creatures again they'll
never inflict their pathetic existence
on what is mine I am free
scp-682 howled in private triumphant
Victory as it rambled through the
streets of this dead World unknown to
humans and especially unknown to the
foundation this was nothing like the
endless office spaces of level 4 because
the darkness negated any possible
depression that scp-682 could develop as
a result of being deprived of other
entities to interact with even then it
was clear that there would be more than
enough entities for scp-682 to destroy
if it got bored while there was no
telling how often entities in the back
room spawn or where they really come
from there never seemed to be a shortage
in the levels where they did exist
scp-682 began to think that level 9 was
in fact the paradise it appeared to be
at first glance Against All Odds
scp-682 had achieved genuine Bliss and
it seemed that nothing could take that
away as scp-682 stood there staring up
into the starless black void of level 9
Sky it was caught off guard by the
sudden presence of what appeared to be a
blue Hyacinth Macaw landing on its back
the bird had given no indication that it
was nearby and because of that it had
somehow taken as cp682 completely by
surprise what's more the reptile was
feeling an unusual sensation with mind
it knew almost instinctively that this
avian entity's name was Jerry and also
it was one of the only beings 682 had
ever encountered that it didn't outright
want to destroy it wasn't that scp-682
like Jerry or even really cared for if
he lived or died there was something
about this unusual Macabre that didn't
trigger the usual disgust response that
every other form of life brought out in
682. this was an admiration or
friendship but more like optimistic
indifference Your Existence is
acceptable Jerry said 682 to its
Newfound winged companion let's go find
some weaklings to kill
weaklings Jerry replied and so 682 was
off again this time with Jerry and tow
it was like the two of them against the
world and together they could take on
anything
scp-682 and Jerry out on adventures
running around and accomplishing great
things in the back rooms 100 Years of
scp-682 and Jerry eventually the asphalt
and suburban houses gave way to an
unpaved dirt path leading through a
field of wheat within moments the
darkness was replaced with a dense fog
and the black of the night sky changed
into the gray of a cloudy afternoon
scp-682 breathed in the moist air and
realized once again it had moved between
levels of the back rooms without knowing
it this was Level 10 the infinite wheat
field at this point the word infinite
was starting to feel cheap some warning
would have been nice as cp682 grumbled
no longer feeling as Serene without the
benefits of level 9's Darkness at least
Jerry was still here there was a silver
lining to everything no
scp-682 stomped its feet on the ground
in building frustration it needed to
find something to tear to Pieces
immediately or might reconsider even its
tolerance to Jerry the Macaw was now its
last resort in case there no other
entities on this level fortunately for
Jerry
scp-682 became alerted by the echoing
sounds of trumpets coming from further
into the wheat field and decided to
investigate Through The Mists of level
10
scp-682 could see the Silhouettes of
several large Stone Towers
scp-682 didn't recognize the exact time
period of the architecture the way a
human might assume they were from the
Middle Ages but it could definitely tell
that these were old it hadn't destroyed
something like this in ages and it
seemed as though it would soon be given
a reason to perched high on the towers
were a small Patrol of goblinoid
creatures wielding bows and arrows these
entities spotted scp-682 around the same
time it spotted them and began to knock
arrows from their Quivers and open fire
relentlessly on the reptile these
ancient projectiles stung but compared
to the disintegration Rays from the
Watchers
scp-682 saw this as a bit of a downgrade
the only real arm that it did to scp-682
was spiritual as the reign of arrows
seemed to startle Jerry and cause the
Macaw to take flight away from scp-682
Jerry get back here you coward
scp-682 shouted to The bird-like Entity
as it disappeared from sight it shook
its head however brief it was it seemed
that the scp-682 and Jerry team up had
come to an end stupid bird he better
hope I don't see him again The Archers
continued to Pepper scp-682 with arrows
but the reptile wasn't about to take
medieval warfare lying down with extreme
speed
scp-682 charged at the nearest Tower and
rammed it head on the impact shook the
structure causing the archers to stumble
and drop some of their arrows despite
the damage the tower hadn't fully
crumbled so as cp682 underwent a brand
new adaptation to settle the score
armored plates converged at the end of
scp-682's tail forming a large
bludgeoning Club similar to that of an
Ankylosaurus with a power and speed of
682's body behind it this bony Mass was
more accurately described as a wrecking
ball and it came in like a wrecking ball
too as the reptile swung its whole body
with enough Force to smash the base of
the tower into pieces as the stone fell
so did The Archers and many were buried
beneath the rubble While others
scattered retreating to farther Towers
while taking pot shots at 682 the
reptile didn't chase them it had bigger
plans it waited until the archers had
made their way into the next few Towers
before grabbing a piece of rubble in its
mouth and chucking it directly up into
the air the chunk of stone flew upwards
and then began to descend rapidly
towards the wheat field below
demonstrating an eye for precision on
par with the siege Engineers of medieval
times
scp-682 swung its club tail at the
perfect moment to hit the falling Stone
and change its course it was a home run
scp-682 scored a direct hit on the top
of the next Tower and repeated its Stone
chucking strategy until the archers
began to get the message this was a war
the likes of which these Freddie freaker
looking demons had never experienced the
hard to destroy reptile roared a
blustering Battle Cry and began to
berate the entities for their weakness
you miscreants deserve this for scaring
Jerry away
scp-682 said without really thinking
what had gotten into it some strange
anomalous effect it pondered this as it
continued to perform its rather
convincing impression of a catapult The
Archers had completely taken cover at
this point afraid to retaliate for fear
of getting a rock to the face not long
after the same trumpet noise could be
heard again and the area around the
towers became a lot less active it did
take scp-682 a moment or two to realize
that the entities had all disappeared
with the sound of that instrument
cowards would be cowards after
the reptile was aching for more of a
fight but at the very least level 10 was
offering something new though not all of
it was new a Smiler peeked out at
scp-682 from between stalks of Wheat and
this time the reptiles simply chose to
ignore The Uncanny grinning bastard and
move on no sense giving it the
satisfaction right
scp-682 followed the dirt path for about
a day during which time it also
encountered a pack of hounds a skin
stealer and who could say how many death
rats that scampered admits the field
after this it came to what appeared to
be some kind of settlement the buildings
here looked much more modern than the
towers and unlike the empty suburbs of
level 9 the reptile could see that there
were actual humans living here from all
appearances this appeared to be a small
town square with an open-air Trading
Post much like a farmer's market in
addition to wheat the humans living in
this settlement had all sorts of goods
on display and could be seen actively
bartering with each other
scp-682 licked its lips none of these
helpless fools knew it was coming malt
town as it was known to wander as in the
back rooms was about to receive a rude
awakening at the hands of the ketter
class SCP while The Archers that have
been encountered earlier posed a
definite threat to those straying too
close to their towers The Entity seemed
to conveniently ignore this humble
little town of course Mercy was not in
scp-682's Playbook except when it came
to Jerry apparently but the Macaw was
gone now and it was time for Carnage
this was going to be fun go check out
could scp-682 be contained in the back
rooms and scp-682 Slaughters through the
back rooms for more back rooms Carnage